-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-, Tony-,
and Grammy Award-winning actor,
singer, and director
you know from his work
in the show "Pose"
and "Kinky Boots" on Broadway.
His movie "Anything's Possible"
is streaming now on Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-I keep telling her
there is no place safer
than right here at home with me.
-Mom, law of averages.
-Fine. Fair enough.
-Wait, what is that?
-It's just this rule we have
where I'm not allowed to ask her
anything that the average mom
won't ask the average girl.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Cellphone chimes ]
-Now I really got to go.
It's so nice to meet you,
"Kha-leed."
-Yeah.
-It's "Kha-lid."
-What is it?
-Kha-lid.
-Kha-lid?
-Mm-hmm.
-You're both failing,
but that's okay.
-You know what?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Billy Porter,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello!
-Resplendent, as always.
Billy, I'm so happy
to have you here in person.
And congratulations
on this film.
Not only did you direct it,
you also wrote music
for the soundtrack.
-I did.
We did the soundtrack --
Republic Records,
who I'm signed to now.
Getting ready
to do my own music.
So get ready for that.
-Very exciting.
Very exciting.
-I'm back. The bitch is back
in the music business.
But, yes,
Justin Tranter and I --
Justin Tranter's camp
and myself,
we wrote five new songs
for the soundtrack.
And we also curated artists
who are queer.
I think I could say
probably like 90% to 95%
of the artists on the soundtrack
are queer.
You got to go listen
to the soundtrack, too.
-Did you -- Was it --
Did you write the songs
and curate the songs --
was that something
you were doing
while you were making the film,
or did you wait till you had
the finished product before?
-Yes, we were doing both.
-Okay, gotcha.
-You know,
I was writing along the way.
Being a music artist
and a musical theater artist,
I've always told stories
through music.
And that's a really,
really important part for me
as I take on
this director's thing.
You know, it's inside of the
music that I find the rhythm,
that I find the music
of the piece.
-I certainly knew your
connection to musical theater.
And that's somewhere, you know,
where you've always shone.
I didn't realize
how young you were
when you knew this
about yourself.
But you were 15 years old
when you went to audition
for "Dreamgirls"?
-[ Laughs ] Okay, so I was bit
by the bug in sixth grade.
-Okay.
-And "Dreamgirls"
came out that year.
-Uh-huh.
-And I was obsessed.
And I was trying to get out.
'Cause I needed to get out,
honey.
-This was getting out --
-Out of my house,
out of my neighborhood,
out of all of it, right?
So, I was getting
"Backstage" magazine.
For those of you
who don't know what that is,
that's the trade magazine
that lists all the auditions
and stuff.
-Gotcha.
-And so I was getting
that magazine at my house
at 15 in Pittsburgh.
And I would circle the auditions
that I would go to
if I had lived in New York City
at the time
and if I was old enough.
So one day when I was 16,
a "Dreamgirls" audition came up,
and it was on a Friday.
And I had the Friday off,
and I had my own money.
And I lied to my mother and said
I was going to a friend's house.
And I went downtown,
bought myself a train ticket,
rode the train for 13 hours,
went to the audition in Chicago.
This is before cellphones
or anything like that.
They told me I was fabulous
and that I was too young
and to keep my eye on the prize.
And I went back on the train.
I went right back
to the train station
and came back home,
crying for 13 hours.
[ Audience aws ]
-And when you got home, did your
mom say, "That took a while"?
-No, she didn't know until,
I would say, maybe right now.
[ Laughter ]
No.
No, she --
[ Applause ]
She has known.
I told this story at some point
somewhere else,
and she was like,
"What did you do?"
Said, "It's over, darling.
I'm 30 years old now."
-But, so, it's interesting,
'cause you were talking about,
you know, wanting
to get out of Pittsburgh,
and then, though,
you ended up going to college
at Carnegie Mellon, which is
a wonderful theater school.
-One of the greatest
in the world.
-How old were you
when you realized
it was right in your backyard?
-I was 17.
-Uh-huh.
-And I was in drama school,
the Creative and Performing Arts
high school,
where we shot the movie,
actually.
-Yes.
-Not the same building,
but the same school.
And my drama teacher and mentor
found out that I was planning
on graduating from high school
and just going to New York.
And I got yanked by my ear,
and they were like,
"You're not going anywhere
but Carnegie Mellon."
And I was like, "What?"
You know.
And it was
right down the street.
And this is what I mean --
this is what we mean
when we talk about opportunity
and access.
I lived 12 -- a 12-minute drive
away from Carnegie Mellon
and had no idea
that it was one of the greatest
drama schools in the world.
Right? It wasn't until
some white people told me.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm grateful.
You know, I'm thankful for that.
You know, 'cause they said, you
know, "You sing like a dream,
you know,
you dance your booty off,
and every time you open up
your mouth to speak,
it's a disaster."
[ Laughter ]
"You need to go learn
how to act."
I'm so grateful somebody,
you know, was looking out.
I call them my angels.
They were looking out for me.
-Well, I mean, that is
the best thing a teacher can do.
Sure, they can teach anybody,
but the thing about talent,
right, you either have it
or you don't.
And I think sometimes teachers,
when they recognize it,
they're like, "Look, we're going
to help you down the path,
but you're going to realize
your own talent.
We're not going to
give it to you,
but we know the place
to point you."
-I was so blessed
to have people like that.
-I want to talk about the movie
and how you went back
and did it in Pittsburgh.
We'll be right back
with more from Billy Porter.